america's cable television companies and
brought to you as a public service by
your cable or satellite provider
the house will come to order
welcome everybody uh to the
international spy museum uh i am mark
stout i'm the former historian of the
international spy museum uh the current
uh museum historian dr vince houghton is
is a way out of town on a on a secret
mission which perhaps you will hear
about in the future
but uh but i'm always delighted to come
back to my old haunts and stamp in
whenever necessary
you've come tonight to what i think is
going to be a wonderful program
that we are putting on in cooperation
with the norwegian embassy
um
because this is a uh this is the story
we're going to be hearing tonight is
about a
world war ii very important and famous
uh and dramatic as you will hear world
war ii raid into norway conducted
primarily by norwegians it was an
obvious thing to partner up with the
norwegian embassy so i'd just like to
say a few words by way of introduction
uh
uh to our uh our our friends here from
the norwegian embassy specifically um
uh yoon oslebo
who is here who's minister councillor
for communications cultural affairs educ
and education at the royal norwegian
embassy
he's been here in serving in washington
for about 10 months on this particular
tour he's served here previously a
decade or so ago i believe
his immediately preceding tour
was in oslo at the foreign ministry
where he's been a number of times but
he's also served uh in good diplomatic
fashion in countries as varied as
mozambique poland switzerland and
morocco
uh yun and indeed the entire norwegian
embassy are good friends of the
international spy museum we've done a
number of really fun and interesting
events over the years with them
we are delighted to work with them again
tonight and to have them here so perhaps
a few words from from our new agent
friends
[Applause]
good evening everyone and uh we are
certainly delighted to to work with the
spy museum um thank you for hosting this
interesting program we're going to hear
about an event that is certainly part of
the history of my own country and
i'm quite happy that it's not it does
not take a
bigger part in shaping the world's
history
because that might have been devastating
so the embassy is pleased to be a
partner just a few days ago
norway celebrated
the 71st anniversary of the surrender of
the nazi occupying forces of the second
world war
now 71 years is a long time it's
long enough for people to forget
it's long enough for new generations
never to learn what happened
and not to speak of
reflecting on the significance of what
happened
historians historians know that they
should never
ask hypothetical questions what would
have happened if they're supposed to
focus on fact and explain through you
know what led to
a certain outcome but
in the case of
uh the heavy water operation at vmwork
in norway
it is a little bit tempting to speculate
what what would our societies have
looked like
if the nazis had succeed had succeeded
in in their ambitions to produce an
atomic bomb
in the interior of telemark county in
norway the germans were producing a key
ingredient
to such a bomb and
some of the production is here in the
room
i'm sure you will hear about that later
uh two initial attempts to stop the
production
failed
and 41 young commandos
lost their lives as a result
the third attempt however
was successful and we all look forward
to hearing neil bascom talk about it
in particular i know that there is a
young man
sitting right here
odin is seven years old and he's here
because his grandmother's brother
was the last of the commandos to leave
the plant after they planted the bomb
frederick kaiser he was one of the
commanders at vermont
and
he is no longer
alive i understand
but it's part of
their family
history so thank you and i look forward
to
listening to neil bascom's presentation
[Applause]
so a few words about neil before we get
started uh neil is a new york times
best-selling and award-winning author of
quite a number of books uh all
non-fiction which tend to focus on
inspiring stories of adventure or
achievement neil studied
economics and english literature an
interesting combination at miami
university in ohio and then worked as a
journalist
in
in europe for a number of years and then
later as an editor at the saint martins
press in new york and he now makes his
living writing books which makes him a
rare uh individual
and he has been
very successful in this endeavor
his first book was hire a historic race
to the sky in the making of a city a
book about new york city
and that was selected for the barnes
noble discover great news great new
writers award and was featured on a
history channel documentary
he then wrote a book called the perfect
mile about roger roger bannister and the
the ultimately successful effort to
break the four-minute mile
his uh third book was red mutiny about
the 1905 mutiny on the battleship
potemkin in the late days of azaris
russia his fourth book which i believe
you can buy back there alongside the
winter fortress was hunting eichmann
about israeli intelligence's mission to
find adolf eichmann and bring him to
israel put in modern terms it's a story
about a rendition
and uh that's what it was and this story
this book was so successful um that a a
young adult edition called nazi hunters
uh was also uh put out and won a number
of awards as well neil's work has been
translated into something like 15
languages featured in several
documentaries and optioned for
film and television projects neil is
among the fortunate few who not only is
able to make his living as a writer but
also gets to live in seattle washington
as you might imagine from somebody who
lives in seattle he is an avid hiker
skier and coffee drinker and as a
seattle resident as i once was he is
therefore definitionally a good guy and
we're very glad to have him neil baskin
[Applause]
i have to lower this urine is taller
than i am
one second
just trying to find my notes which you
might have taken
[Laughter]
i will be saying that speech again
i want to thank the
international spy museum and the
norwegian embassy for co-sponsoring this
event and
thank you all for coming uh this evening
now uh last week i was driving in
seattle and i was listening to npr and i
was listening to this
interview of chris anderson who runs the
ted talks
and over the course of the interview i
was listening avidly because i was about
to go on book tour
and chris said that the longest you can
possibly maintain an audience's
attention
is 18 minutes
you guys will be here for roughly two
and a half hours
so hold tight
now as mark introduced i've written uh
quite a few different kinds of books
skyscrapers and four minute miles and
czars russia
high school kids building robots
and people often ask me you know
what's what's going on here uh what's
the theme why why all this disparate uh
kinds of books
now my wife says i think
ungenerously that i choose my books
based on where i want to travel next
now norway is a lovely place to travel
so that may be slightly accurate
but i choose my books
i focus on stories and this may be
somewhat of a cliche but it's it's the
kind of stories that grab me stories
about ordinary people
doing extraordinary things
and this story of the atomic sabotage by
norwegians
definitely classifies within that
now this is a story
about atomic sabotage about atomic
physics about heavy water it has some
heavy stuff in it
but i don't want to lose sight and i
don't want you to lose sight of what is
important in this story
and i'd like to read a letter that
lifetron stat here
who is a scientist
norwegian scientist chemist
who basically orchestrated
all these sabotages
and devoted the rest of his life towards
it
he was in london escaped norway went to
london worked with the british and he
wrote this series of letters to his
family who was still back in norway
many of them to his young daughter
sidsel
his son life was was too young to read
but in one of these written in 1943 he
tried to explain to sidsel why he was
away because she was very upset
and i'd like to read it here a part of
it here tonight
we have to do everything for our land to
make it free again
when we say our fatherland we don't just
mean the land which is beautiful and we
also love
but also everything else we love at home
mother little boy and you and all the
other fathers and mothers and children
i also mean all the wonderful memories
from the time we ourselves were small
and from later when we had children of
our own
our home villages with the hills and
mountains and forests the lakes and
ponds and rivers and streams and
waterfalls and fjords
the smell of new hay in summer of
birches and spring of the sea and the
big forest
and even the biting winter cold
everything
norwegian songs and music and so much
much more
that's our fatherland
that's what we have to struggle
to get back
that's why i'm here
now let's turn to atomic physics you
guys are all very excited i can see
but i think it's important to describe
what heavy water is what why it is
important and i'll i'll i'll do this in
a very basic way because that's
how my understanding of it is
you have regular h2o you have water
okay which you can
drink it has hydrogen hydrogen has a
single electron and a single proton
heavy water d2o
deuterium
it's a variant or what's called an
isotope of hydrogen
it actually has a neutron
within the nucleus makes it heavier
you can see it here
now why that's important is
in the course of the war the germans and
the americans were attempting to build
heavy water reactors self-sustaining
nuclear reactors
and they needed a moderator
okay a heavy water or graphite
where you have these neutrons flinging
around within this reactor and you need
to slow them down to foster the fission
and the thing that h2o does if you have
these neutrons flinging around it might
slow them down but absorbs that those
flinging around neutrons stealing them
away from a potential chain reaction
d2o heavy water
doesn't absorb them
they bombard they slow and the neutrons
move on
this fosters the chain reaction
now these heavy water reactors
the idea and the germans knew this and
the americans knew this by 1942 is if
you have a heavy water reactor it will
breed plutonium
and if you have plutonium you have the
basics for an atomic bomb
this is the atomic bomb explosion over
nagasaki this was a plutonium bomb
now when many people talk about
the
german atomic bomb program
they talk about varner heisenberg this
gentleman
on the far left
at the start of the war the americans
and germans were basically at the same
place they both knew
after the first splitting of the atom
that the potential for atomic power or
an atomic weapon
was very viable
so they both moved forward on programs
heisenberg was part of that program he
was a genius he was a theoretical
physicist he had won the nobel prize in
his early 30s
but he wasn't the key man of the german
atomic bomb program
the gentleman on your far right was dr
kurt diebner
he worked in the army ordinance
department and for years through the
mid-30s he was telling his bosses we
should focus on atomic physics it's the
future and his bosses kept coming back
to him and saying
stop with this quote unquote atomic
malarkey
and so
he didn't move forward and then the
splitting of the atom happened and
suddenly kurt diebner was elevated into
the role as the head of the german
uranium club
he starts basic research heisenberg
provides a lot of it but deebner is the
one in charge he's part of the nazi
party he very much wants an atomic bomb
now one of the key things he needs the
reason we're here tonight
is
heavy water
and there was a single plant in all the
world
that produced it in any quantity a place
called vermock
it's located about 100 miles west of
oslo
it's set on the edge of this
ice bound precipice
it's on the edge of a place of about 30
3 500 square miles called the vida which
is this plateau of
ice and rock and most often snow
now it's very hard to make heavy water
they were doing it with electrolysis so
you need a lot of free or cheap
hydroelectric power
and vermock was a hydroelectric plant
that also produced hydrogen for
fertilizer it was the perfect place to
build a heavy water factory
norris kidro the norwegian industrial
concern was the one who
financed it
built it
and in 1940
the germans came calling
we want all your heavy water as much as
you can give us
in norse kidro the head of norskedro
said well
what do you need that for
and the germans kurt diebner and his
engineers that he sent
said well we can't tell you
no heavy water for the germans
until
the spring of 1940
when the germans occupied norway rather
quickly
they went to vermouth diebner sent his
engineers and his scientists and told
them to ramp up production first
two-fold then five-fold then ten-fold
as much heavy water as could be produced
they wanted
now the problem for
dr kurt diebner and his plans on
building out the heavy water plant and
getting as much as possible he needed
what he said was five tons for his
self-sustaining reactors
i will introduce live tronstadt now
now tron said just as a little
background
tron stat was raised by a single mother
several siblings
he was very smart they didn't have much
money
he tried he pulled himself up in the
american way by his bootstraps
studied in germany studied
in england
was very well regarded as a student came
back and was ready to start his life
with his
childhood sweetheart whose name was
bassa
now tronstadt asked vassa at this point
in time in his early thirties
i can do one of two things
and you need to help me decide i can be
a teacher which is what i love to do
or
i can make as much money as you want me
to make
i can work for for industry
and we can be quite wealthy and bassa
said i want you to be a teacher
and he became an exceptional teacher
but like tron statues you'll get to know
over the course of this talk was a very
vigorous man he couldn't sit still he
was constantly working constantly doing
and so
he turns out to make a lot of money too
and he did that by consulting with these
industrial concerns in the mid thirties
he decided that
heavy water had recently been discovered
no one was able to produce it in any
quantity
he had this hydroelectric plant and this
hydrogen factory wouldn't it be great if
we see if we can
build something that produces it in
great quantity
and he does it
and it is a financial and utter economic
disaster for north kidro nobody wants it
nobody's interested
of course until the splitting of the
atom until people realize
what it's worth is
now tronstadt's ambition with it was
just as a pure science just to see if it
could be done as he said
first experiment practical application
later i'm not sure how norse kedro felt
about that
they used to joke at norris hedro that
uh
that heavy water was it's it's most
useful property would be to make skating
rinks because it froze
at a slightly higher
temperature the germans invade in
lifetron's that goes underground
and he starts spying
on the germans what they're doing and in
particular he starts spying on vermouth
and the increase in production and why
they're doing it
the gestapo discovers what he's doing
he's up in trondheim he hears their
coming for him he escapes by train to
oslo
puts his family up at his childhood home
skis across the border to sweden
goes to london
and quite quickly
although the british scientific
community said tronstep what we want you
to do is develop scientific technology
for us and what tronstedt said was i
want to fight
i want to fight for my country
now the reason i know this is because i
was able thanks to life's son
to assemble the diaries that life wrote
from the time he got on that train the
first entry is on that train when he's
going down to oslo
to the moment of his death
daily entries on what he was thinking
feeling
doing
and he wanted to fight
and he quickly became and found himself
at the nexus of the norwegian high
command which was now exiled the
norwegian government was exiled in
britain
here he is in his uniform he said the
nexus of the high command and the
british soe the special operations
executive as many of you some of you may
know is called i think most famously the
ministry of ungentlemanly warfare
they are the commandos they are the ones
who go behind enemy lines
and perform operations
so that is tronstadt's role and high on
his list
is attacking
vermont
he partners up with a man named colonel
wilson
he was the head of the british soe in
norway
and they start hashing up plans
to go
after vermont
now this is by about april of 1942
and by april of 1942 the allies are
advancing in their atomic research
they're they're realizing of course that
this is possible this can happen
and they also realize that with the
german science
they will also be in the same place
and they know now that heavy water is
critical and they also know it will be
used in a breeder reaction potentially
for plutonium
and this is one of my favorite letters
in this story because it's so bland
but it really is the impetus
for all that happens afterwards it was
written april 23 1942 by the
scientists of the tube alloys committee
the british atomic program
and they write to churchill
since experiments have confirmed that
element 94 that's plutonium
would be good for military purposes
and since this element is best prepared
in systems involving the use of heavy
water
the committee recommends that attempt
should if possible
be made to stop norskedro production
summer 1942. churchill and roosevelt
looking rather cheery here
sit down in hyde park and discuss two
things
the invasion of mainland europe
and two what to do about the atomic
bomb program
it is here where the first discussions
move forward that the americans will
take over and the british will advise
but this is the beginning of the
manhattan project
now at this very meaning they discussed
the heavy water and they discussed what
was happening at vermont and churchill
writes in his in his memoirs of this
eerie sinister term named heavy water
and what is decided by the summer of
1942 by churchill is
we need to hit it we need to do whatever
we want we can to hit it and the mission
is on
einer schinerland
is really
if the british had a secret weapon in
tronstadt tronstead had a secret weapon
in einer
einer was born on beside the dam at lake
moss which provided the water
to the hydroelectric plant this is a
place where it's snowbound about six
months of the year it's a place where
being self-reliant is a necessity if
something is broken you fix it
einer boasts that he was born with skis
on his feet
he was an expert skier and expert hunter
he was a winter survivalist
and he was an engineer who worked for
norskedro
now here's einer he's this is the
cheeriest picture i could find einer
he looks very happy
and i love this picture because if i
identify one thing with einer skinner
lin it's toughness
something very different from the face
you see here but he was probably the
toughest person i read about researched
over the course of this story
he wanted to fight when germans came and
occupied his village
and so one day
he goes to his mother and says well i'm
going to go on a skiing trip i'm going
to go up into the mountains i have my
rifle i'm on my own i'm gonna go hunting
reindeer i will see you in three weeks
instead of going north iron goes
southwest to the coast
on his way he crashes while skiing i
don't know how that happened he didn't
record it
and he hurts his knee badly
but he reaches the coast he joins
together with a couple other guys and
they have this ambition to hijack a
steamer by gunboat and steam it across
the north sea and reach scotland
it's a decent plan
the problem is einer's knee is worse and
worse and worse he's injured terribly
and so he goes to the doctor he goes to
a hospital and says i need surgery on
this knee
will you perform it today
and they say we will
say well you'll you'll need a week or
two to recover you know the anesthesia
the the surgery and einer says today now
no anesthetic
and so einer
writes of this experience of the pain of
holding the sides of the hospital bed
the worst pain he had experienced but he
had the surgery not 24 hours later he
was on that steamer in command of the
ship
god with another couple of other
gentlemen
they steamed it across they reached
scotland
and einer's thinking this whole time
well you know i'm going to be trained to
fight over the course of three months or
six months and i'm going to become a
trained soldier and then i'll be able to
fight
well life tron's that here is that
there's this young man from rukan from
the ru khan area which is where vermont
is located
who's in town
and so tronstet sends the man to get
einer on a train directly to london
brings einer into his office and says
you're leaving in a week
you are going to be my spy
on the ground
you're going to provide information to
me on the plant
and einer of course says yes the
security man
he gets one week of training one week of
parachute training mixed with wireless
radio training
and then einer is on a
halifax bomber
cruising across the north sea then over
norway
there's a hole in the bottom of the
plane that he's going to jump through
and now the trouble is that einer is
afraid of heights
and tough as he is
you know i love i love history because
there's some books written on this and
in every book written on it there's
einer in the plane and he like hurls
himself through that hole
well the reports the british keep
everything i love the british
um the british keep
dispatch reports
of of drop operations
and the dispatcher writes of of
basically having to you know shove einer
through the hole
um
to get him down
but einer jumps down
lands on that bum knee
skis home
hello mother
back from my skiing vacation
and he begins to spy on vermont he
begins to live this double life
and i can't say this with a hundred
percent accuracy
but einer was was a spy on the ground
for the soe for over three years
probably one of the longest standing soe
spies
and he provided an absolute
wealth of information
he provided guard rotations he provided
production quotas he provided the what
locks were on the door where the
stairwells were everything you would
need to know
in fact they would joke that they had so
much information on vermont they could
build it themselves in britain
that's what einer and the people who
helped him
produced for life tron step
but what to do about it
what operation how do we destroy vermont
how do we perform
what churchill and roosevelt want us to
do
now the allies particularly the
americans maybe this is an american
thing
they want to go the the fast
course they want to bomb it
just destroy it
from the air
like tron said here's this plan and he
says no
and he says no for two reasons one
there are a lot of civilians that live
around that area north kidro it's a
norse kidro town rupan there's over 5000
people living there any bombing
operation is going to kill a number of
civilians
and two
this plant is tens and tens of thousands
of pounds of concrete stone steel and
the heavy water facility is in the
basement
now tronstead said you could bomb that
thing day and night and you're not going
to touch that heavy water plant
and so the allies back off that plan and
tronset says well what i think we should
do is send in some norwegians who know
the country send a small team and will
handle it
and no offense
but the british did not trust the
norwegians to do it properly they just
didn't have the experience at that point
they thought to perform such an
operation
so they decide
something else
they decide to send two teams of british
royal engineers sappers parachutists
to go into
this area
land by glider plane
okay
a halifax would tow two glider planes
across the north sea
they would release them over the
the drop site they would float down and
land in this
welcome countryside called the vida
now tron said is informing to them that
this you know we we should we should
talk about this and you know this is a
hard place to land a hard place to be
i'll give you an idea of how little the
british knew of this area
this operation was scheduled to happen
in likely november of 1942
and there's a series of correspondents
legitimate correspondents talking about
how we're going to provide the royal
engineers with bicycles
the idea was there would be bicycles on
the glider plane
they would take them out
and they would bite down to the plant in
late november
which is probably a pretty bad idea
given it's likely snowbound
now this operation was called operation
freshman it was called operation
freshman because gliders had never been
used by the allies in combat operations
before
operation freshman
now tronstead did manage to
have
a four-man team led by
paulson up here at the top a four-man
norwegian team these were norwegians
young norwegians much like
schinderland who
itched to fight
took whatever fishing vessels some went
around the world to reach britain to be
trained the select of the select were
chosen to be part of the norwegian
independent company
which was a soe run
group of norwegians who they trained
first basic training and commando
training and basically then spy training
the idea was pouson this operation
grouse would land
they landed in october 19 october 19
1942 they landed in the area
they skied
and i say they skied they had so much
equipment
that to go the number of miles they
needed to go they would ski a distance
of six or seven miles stop drop their
bags go back six or seven miles pick up
the second half of their bags and ski
back again
over the course of over
roughly ten days to reach the landing
site they were on the ground they were
preparing it they were setting up what
was called their eureka rebecca beacon
which was this
long story short homing device for the
planes to to be able to spot the landing
site
now
i don't want to forget the
the royal engineers
because these were very brave young men
who were told
very little of what they were getting
into
they were told simply that this was an
important operation
they were not told they were going to
norway
but they were told it was important
enough that it could decide the fate of
the war
they were asked
who wants to participate
every man in the company stepped forward
mid november
1942
operation freshman begins this is the
horse a glider that you see
there the glider pilots called the horse
a glider they nicknamed it the wooden
coffin
being inside of it was as they described
like being inside of a or being on top
of a bucking bronco or riding a roller
coaster it was made of wood
it had a corrugated steel floor
because there was so much vomit
they had harnesses but they did very
little
and they were on this on a mission
across the north sea the furthest that
any gliders had ever been towed
and the idea again
was to land
and then commence the operation
it did not go as planned
newt houglin the radio operator for
operation grouse sent
a sent a transmission early that morning
saying all the weather is clear
by the evening when these planes finally
arrived in the dark the cloud cover had
lowered the wind had picked up the cold
had deepened
and it was very different place
what we do know is that
the first glider the tow rope snapped
the first glider glider a it was called
crashed into a mountain sign
the second
halifax glider
pair were not exactly sure what happened
what we do know is that they separated
the other glider crashed into a hillside
what we suspect is the halifax circled
around to see
where the glider had landed it too
crashed
those who were not killed on impact
were captured
by the germans some of them were
tortured
interrogated and then
sadly killed
beside the lofts of life the 41 men
the germans now know
the allies are coming
if they suspected it before they knew
now
vermouth was already a natural force set
on the edge of this precipice in this
very deep valley
but now it became even more so
they doubled the security they doubled
the number of guards they increased the
minefields they fortified the single
lane suspension bridge any subsequent
operation against vermouth would be
what the germans thought
was impossible
not within 24 hours of the catastrophe
of operation freshmen
life tronstadt and colonel wilson went
to combined operations which was in
charge of operation freshmen and said we
would like to take over this mission
let us
do our jobs
and they in many ways sort of washed
their hands of it they said please
it had been such a
disaster
and so tron stat
selects decides this is what we're going
to do
with wilson
we are going to send a six-man team
operation gunner side this is five
i can count
we will send a six-man team
they will drop
into the area into the vita they will
connect up with operation grouse
together they will move towards the
plant
and destroy it
now while operation freshman the idea
was to both hit the heavy water facility
in the basement but also to eliminate
some other parts of the plant this
operation was solely focused on
destroying the basement level
heavy water plant
it was led by the young joaquim
ronenberg
there on the bottom your right
young man no combat experience
his second in command was newt howkalib
now newt howkalid his nickname this this
tells you everything you need to know
about how klit his nickname was bonzo
he was actually born in brooklyn
returned to norway when he was a young
child
he was a bit of a rascal
when the germans evaded he fought the
battle of norway
he went underground
and then like many others found his way
to england to be trained
this six-man team led by ronenberg who
although he didn't have combat
experience he was as all his
all his reports and again i had all the
reports that the british have during the
training of these men
he was as they said a natural leader
cunning
the men follow him
without question
he became so good at these training
operations that they were doing in
scotland
that he
then became in charge of them and led
the norwegians many of them most of them
older than he was
on these missions
so now operation gunner side is moving
forward they are now training on the
mock plant that tronstet sets up
they are preparing sleeping bags and
rations and every guns and everything
they need for this operation and
roanenberg was very
intensive about preparations
there's a number of reasons why things
delayed for over the course of two
months
mostly the weather the weather over the
north sea and in norway and
december january is not so
nice
and so a dropping operation was delayed
one after the next they finally at one
point are on a plane going there they're
they're going across the norwegian coast
and they're hit by anti-aircraft
artillery the plane barely stumbles home
now the trouble with all that delay
is that operation grouse is still there
this looks like a cozy place to spend
your winter doesn't it
after freshman operation grouse has to
escape there's a manhunt
for anyone who was involved in helping
the british
so these gentlemen escape up into the
vita
a places legend has it it grows so cold
so fast that flames freeze in the fire
they go up to a cabin a one-room cabin
these four men they have very little
food they have very little assistance
and now they need to survive the winter
alone
they survive basically off of reindeer
they hunt reindeer they eat only
reindeer they become such connoisseurs
of of reindeer that that they would
write about their favorite parts of the
reindeer
does anyone want to know the favorite
part of the reindeer anybody
yes
do you know
no okay
this may be a little gruesome but
there's fat behind the eyelid that
apparently is quite delectable
they survive but they're getting weaker
and weaker
thankfully
in mid february gunnerside finally
lands
now
a lot of things aren't going well
this is another factor they land and
what the men called the worst blizzard
they had ever seen hit a blizzard so
strong that they were literally lifted
off of their feet and thrown backwards
by the gusts of wind
they housed themselves in a cabin they
luckily find
they waited out for five days they
emerged in this landscape that looks as
they said totally transformed by snow
they finally meet together operation
gunnerside operation grouse these 10 men
and i won't forget schindelind here at
some points in time he was staying with
operation grouse in the cabin he was
providing them batteries for their
wireless transmissions he was skiing
constantly back and forth
continuing to provide intelligence
but he is not on this mission
he in some ways is too important
much like newt houglin the other radio
operator to go on this so it's nine men
that are going to participate in
operation gunnerside they meet together
they go to a cabin that overlooks
their mooc and they decide how they're
going to hit the plant
now the germans as i said now suspect
that the the attack is going to come
across the lone suspension bridge
doubly guarded
two gates
if they manage to eliminate the guards
there will most certainly be an alert so
they discount that
secondly they can come down from the
mountains that you see above vermouth if
you see you can see the pipelines
actually the where the water is coming
down
that feeds the hydroelectric plant they
could come down there there's actually a
stairwell there
the problem is there's mine fields
littered all over that place
so they decide not to do that
life johnstadt back in london
was looking at aerial photographs and
noticed
of course there's this valley
and there's some trees that growing up
that maybe you can go down the valley
and just climb up and then you know make
your way down the railway line that hugs
the edge of this cliffside and reached
the plant
well the local boys this operation
grouse which were pretty much all local
boys from rucon
said
no
i mean these are boys whose parents
would say
you know at 10 or 11 years old we'll go
out onto the vita and have a great three
days camping you know
but their parents told them never
climb
this cliff sign at one point a car
crashes over
in their youth and men have to repel
down with ropes that's how steep parts
of it were
tronset says maybe you should do this
howklid now is there and says i think
that's a great idea bonzo's all for it
ronenberg's not sure
but they have this idea they go down
they climb up they'll go the railway
line this will be the only way they can
get in
without alerting anybody
so ronenberg takes a vote
and he wants the men to have to
participate in the decision to be bought
in on the decision and they vote to a
man to climb this cliffside
and so on the night of february 27th
28th
they ski down from their cabin they take
off their skis at some point because
it's too steep they hike down
they almost get mowed over by a bus of
german soldiers coming up to the plant
they reached down into the valley
and now they're at the base of this
500-foot cliffs that they need to climb
and roanenberg later recalls saying i
ronamerg later said
it looked like being on a street and
looking up at a skyscraper and that's
what he needed to climb
but of course these norwegians they they
do it
they managed to to scale
scramble up this cliffside they reach
the railway line they move down they
wait till the guard rotation shift
they snap the lock
on the gate
they split into two teams the covering
party led by alkalid and ronenberg leads
the two two men demolition teams
they reach the plant they have
everything they need to know they know
the door is going to be open they reach
the door
and the door is shut
thankfully they had everything they
needed to know as i said earlier about
this plant they knew that there was this
little tunnel that carried pipes into
the plant and so they decided to go up
this ladder
they shimmy through this
rough concrete tunnel they drop into the
basement level of vermouth and there's
nobody there
the germans never thought that anyone
could possibly
get
inside
so they left it unguarded
there was a single foreman
watching over the heavy water plant
he although scared was not putting up
any resistance
to these men who were coming in in
british uniforms saying they were
british-speaking norwegian very well
and
they set the explosives
perfectly there's an explosion
they're running out
they're throwing themselves down this
cliff side and they're on the run
now i in some of these preset
presentations i like to say that's half
the book
that's half the story
there is much more it literally is the
halfway point of the book
because
what the what they did not expect was
that the germans needed this heavy water
so badly
that although they destroyed the supply
they destroyed the machinery within the
span of roughly five months they
reconstituted the plant it was producing
heavy water again and not only was very
much producing heavy water again but
down in rue conn there were two
hydroelectric
facilities that now
uh
two hydrogen facilities that now are
being converted to produce heavy water
as well
but i will leave you
to
read the book to figure that out
but what i do want to sort of end with
um
are some themes that come out of this
story that i think are important to
highlight
the first as i mentioned with shinoland
was toughness how tough they were
and i'll give you one example klaus
helberg
klaus who was from rucon and was part of
operation grouse
after this
after the gunner side operation there
was an even more massive manhunt the
germans voided on the occupation of
norway entering the vita they avoided it
they went around it
now heinrich phelas the head of the ss
in norway
is so upset at this that he decides to
send an army into the vita
many of them not perfectly good skiers
but some of them
good ones
cause hubbard waits this out in oslo a
friend writes him a letter from rupcon
saying it's over you're safe to return
the letter was wrong
klaus is at one of the cabins where they
had buried some explosives he had his
cross-country skis off he was warming
himself in the cabin when he sees out
the window three
german skiers coming towards him now to
reach this cabin he had already skied
roughly 25 miles
and
seems like a long distance to me
and he sees them and he throws on his
cross-country skis and he's off
and he's thinking pretty good about
himself because you know this is his
terrain and he's an expert cross-country
skier and he distanced themselves rather
quickly from two of them but there's one
austrian skier who's holding on tight
and they ski for hours
tough
and what hellberg notices is when he
goes uphill he gains distance and when
he goes downhill the austrian closes the
gap
so klaus decides that he's going to
climb every hillock every mountain every
little bump he can find to get away
and this goes on and on
and the austrian won't give up
and so finally klaus having enough
turns
stops turns
levels his gun
and waits for the german to shoot
his theory is that the setting sun is in
his eyes this austrian is tired he's
nervous and he's not going to have very
good aim and he's klaus is tired of
skiing
so pop pop pop pop pop the german misses
klaus levels one shot shoots wounds the
austrian falls over his skis and klauses
off now quickly needing to ski because
he knows more men are coming
continuing to ski klaus skis off a cliff
in the middle of the night
50 feet 60 feet he thought
lands breaks his arm dislocates his
shoulder gets up
skis another far distance into the
morning
one pole
to a village
i will leave out the story where he
lands himself into a hotel that the
goshidapo
takes over
that evening
the second thing i would i would raise
as a theme is sacrifice how much these
men sacrificed
for the war for what they were doing
shinolin for one his two brothers were
taken by the gestapo imprisoned outside
of oslo
for almost a year
his best friend was seized interrogated
tortured over the span of two months
trying to find out information about
what einer was doing
but the person i'll bring out here is is
mostly is halkalid
how glued after this operation decides
he's going to stay in norway he's going
to build resistant cells which was
essential because of the fact that there
would need to be another last minute
sabotage the sinking of the
hedro ferry carrying the heavy water
away
but at one point alkalid is in oslo
collecting some forged documents for his
budding resistance circle
and hakkalid had been living underground
now
since the invasion of norway so now
going on over three years had not seen
his wife had not seen his parents had
not seen his sister
any family because it's a bad idea
and he's in this apartment a door
there's a knock on the door and
someone comes in and he hears his
father's voice
and there's nothing that howkled wants
to do more
than push open that door embrace his
father see him but he can't
it was the last time he would have a
chance to see his father his father was
taken by the gestapo soon afterwards
was imprisoned and by the time he left
prison he was broken and died soon after
sacrifice
how klud wrote in his norwegian memoir
not
for some reason the american or the
english edition did not have it but he
wrote a dedication to his father in his
memoir
and the education read he died not
knowing why
the last thing i would say is the theme
would be teamwork
now again much like that story about
skinnerlin jumping through that hole
with elan and which wasn't really the
case
you hear and read and see movies about
this story
and these gentlemen
don't have doubts
they're gung-ho the whole way through
they're bonzos the whole way
when that's not the case
pausing recounts as the head of
operation grouse after being in this
cabin in the vida for over two months
now again remember this is now winter in
norway it's probably light only a few
hours a day it's very cold they're
surviving off only reindeer they only
have each other they're in this cabin
they don't have any they don't have any
electricity it's dark
and they're going slightly mad in some
ways
and poussin writes of losing hope
of
wondering when gunner side is ever going
to get there is any of this worth it why
are we putting up with this why can't we
just go ski down into recon where our
families are
and experience in real life those dreams
that they were having of platters of
food being brought to them to the table
and pausa knew that if you didn't do
something about it if he didn't make a
change they were not going to make it
through that winter
and the fact is if they did not make it
through that winter if operation grouse
did not survive gunnerside never would
have been a success never would have
happened
so there's this wonderful scene where
these these four men began telling each
other stories
to entertain each other to keep the time
going to sort of build this teamwork
that they were in this together
and klaus recounts uh of
telling terrible poetry apparently he
was a terrible poet
um and powerson who was a really good
hunter
had a family and on his family wall they
have the ten thousand rules of hunting
these four guys knew those by well by
the end of the winter
arne hailstrip was a plumber
he dissected plumbing for these guys by
the end of the war they could fix any
toilet any place with a plumbing problem
but as much as it's kind of funny it's
it brings
to sort of light this idea of teamwork
of how important it was it's what
sustained these guys it both sustained
grouse and its sustained gunner side
over critical moments
i'll conclude with
two short things one
there's a lot of at least historically
was vermouth important was this
operation important
we know
in june of 1942 the germans decided in a
meeting with albert speer that they are
not going to move forward with the
manhattan project
and so all the money and all the
resources that the americans threw at
this problem the germans are not going
to do that
and so many
say
that yes this mission was brave because
these gentlemen didn't know it was
didn't know what the the allies what the
germans were doing and that is
definitely the case
but what we do also know
is at this june meeting they decide we
will continue with atomic research
and deepner is told if you manage to
produce a self-sustaining reactor we
will shower you with resources
was it the critical difference the fact
that he didn't have heavy water for that
i would say it's part of the reason
that the germans never attained a heavy
reactor and never moved forward with
a bomb program dabner himself credits at
the end of the war the norwegian
sabotage stopped him from a reactor
stopped them from plutonium and stopped
the bomb program
my opinion is it was part of the reason
i'll conclude with life chance that who
finally got his wish to fight
not just in london but to go
into his country parachute into his
country and lead a small army
in the resistance to repel the germans
out
he was killed early
in 1945 by a collaborator
he never got to see
the freedom of norway
but i want to bring back the reason
these guys were fighting again
because as much again as it was about
atomic physics and about stopping
hitler's bomb
they were doing it for their towns and
their villages
and transat wrote a letter to his wife
that was kept in a safe in london that
he gave the secretary the key and said
in the event of my death i want you to
give this to my wife
and life tronstead jr
gave me this letter and read it to me it
was in norwegian i do not speak
norwegian
but read it to me in norwegian and
translated it for me and i promised him
that i would read it and talk about it
when i gave these talks
dearest bassa
i have the honor to lead an important
expedition home which will be of great
importance to norway's future
it is in line with the course i chose on
april 9 1940
to put all my effort and ability toward
our country's welfare
the war is singing its last verse
and it requires every effort from all
who would call themselves men
you will understand that won't you
we have had so many magical happy years
and my highest wish is to continue that
happy life together
but should the almighty have another
course for me
know that my last thought was a view
time is short
but if all will not go well don't feel
sorry for me
i am completely happy and thankful for
what i have had in life
even though i very much would like to
live to help norway back to its feet
i wish the best for sitzel and life
i look forward to seeing them all again
and then the letter was signed your
beloved
that was life john's step thank you very
much
[Applause]
i'll try that one all right uh so we've
uh we've got a time for a few questions
uh if anybody has questions for neil i'm
sure there must be one or two out there
uh all right while you're pondering your
questions i'm going to assert my
prerogative then to ask the first one um
so these norwegian commandos were
human not you know not superman but
pretty remarkable individuals who did
something really amazing um after the
war did they
go and become plumbers again uh what uh
i i imagine men who are capable of doing
this sort of thing and then who do it um
you know i imagine them you know going
into the military or becoming war
correspondents or you know something
like that do you know anything about
their sort of post-war lives sure um
some of them continued in the military
um for instance palestine did haukelid
did roanenberg became a
broadcaster
klaus hellberg was
for
many seasons a tour guide in the vita
they all took sort of different courses
but what i would say about their post
war lives
are two things
one these episodes in this life that
they lived there
sort of
ins
imprinted itself on them
sometimes in in
in haunting ways
einer skinner and schindelin's daughter
told me that
you would never approach einer from
behind
because he was always
he had lived underground he had lived in
a cabin where at any moment the germans
could come
and
he never
lost that
some of them went to sort of heal their
wounds by going into the woods for for
weeks at a time
i think newt houghlin has the sort of in
some ways the most extraordinary story
because he and himself felt wounded
psychologically after all this time
and
he decided to join the
lived quite a life he joined the contiki
expedition
he was the radio operator on the contiki
so he
you know lived another extraordinary
life and i think they all did
in their own ways
the other thing i would say is they were
very tight-knit
most of them
over the course of the rest of their
lives many of them gathered every year
at a hunting cabin
in the south
and
talked war stories but also just i think
in some ways nobody else understood them
yeah gentlemen right here in the front
row if you'll hold on one second we've
got a microphone coming for
c-span
thank you so much for your interesting
and thoughtful presentation
my name is ibrahim avedo i happen to
serve at the american embassy in oslo
and recall visiting the
underground underground museum and acura
shoes i recall there was a mention of
this uh episode uh the the
the bombing of the uh um heavy water
facility
and this uh museum is documented the
first act of resistance was for the
sinking of the troop carrier the blocker
which sunk 1500 the
the german when they entered oslo fjord
on april the 9th 1940 were not able to
catch
uh they did not have enough force to to
to capture the city they also and that
enabled the king to escape
so that underground museum was really a
major source of inspiration and
information about the resistance to the
nazi occupation no i i absolutely agree
with you i mean the norwegian resistance
museum
um was both a absolute resource for me i
mean their archives are tremendous and i
i focus on this story of vermouth and i
talk about the norwegian independent
company but i think also post-war to a
man
these individuals says their most
important job was not vermouth
it was other operations they were on
there were quite a number of company
ling or norwegian independence
men many of them lost their lives
they participated in scores of
operations and if you read life tron
sets diaries vermouth is definitely in
there it's in there you know every month
or so there's a little mention of it
but there's the litany of of other
operations they all were named after
many of them were named after birds um
so there's uh
you know
it's very it's a fascinating the whole
story of the norwegian independent
company uh the young gentleman in the
third row in from the aisle uh well
well all right
we'll take but we'll take both of them
they both had their hands up
go ahead
what's a mind field
and if we want to get the one from
here as well
um if the germans
kept making the heavy water why didn't
they continue with the bomb program
so
the minefield first of all a minefield
is basically the the germans and other
other countries they they put these
explosives underneath the ground okay
and they have a setting that can
explode
them
and
many of them
most of them were taken away after the
war pretty much all of them in the very
milk area so they're totally safe now
the question about
the
how does it reach
like how does it react like explode
how does it explode
in many circumstances it's the weight
so let's say you um let's say an animal
is is going through
a minefield
uh if if a hoof stepped on it that
weight would trigger it
to go off
the question of
what did they continue to do because the
germans reconstituted the plant
the allies in some ways got their way
there was a major bombing mission with
hundreds of b-17 and b-24 bombers
exactly what tron staff predicted would
happen happened
um the plant was not touched
a number of civilians were killed
but the
the consequence of that although the
heavy water facility was not
um stopped the germans decided at that
point
i read a report that one german official
sent
from
from rukan to
berlin saying
the norwegians have made a national
sport
quote unquote of
sabotaging their mooc
we need to move it
and so
you find that in february the february
of of 1944 they in fact begin to
disassemble the plant begin to bring all
the heavy water into barrels and as i
mentioned very briefly that sets the
stage for
the last minute sabotage that newt how
could perform to
end once and for all
the german use of heavy water from
norway
other questions
uh gentlemen back there well we'll come
back to you forget a chance
was there any connection or contact
between uh
these people and their efforts and
moberg the american baseball player and
linguist who was supposed to survey uh
werner heisenberg
yes so um
moe i love the story of moberg um you
know baseball player turned spy uh
there's a wonderful book called the the
catcher is a spy
i believe that's the the title
and um
his mission and it's one of the reasons
i actually turned onto this topic
because i found that so fascinating that
that mo would go to uh germany and his
the plan was if heisenberg if it was
clear that heisenberg was participating
in this potentially to kill him
but he had no contact at all
this was the american oss
handling these operations and there was
a clear demarcation
between the soe and the oss in terms of
norway in these operations
other questions
all right we'll take we'll take one more
here and then we'll uh we'll call it an
evening
go ahead what does heavy water look like
ooh
good question that's a fantastic
question
it looks exactly like regular water you
can't tell the difference
it looks just like this
and in fact one could argue there's
heavy water in a very small quantity in
here there's one molecule for every 41
million molecules of regular water but
it looks the same and some say it tastes
the same
but i don't suggest drinking it
um
it does
scientists have have shown sort of
if you drink it in large quantities
change some biological processes which
is one of the reasons they built the
plant is because they thought one of the
heads of norse kidro thought that heavy
water would cure cancer
it has not proven to do that
but it looks just the same
well on on that note let me just uh let
me just mention for those of you who
didn't see it when we come in i believe
we have back there downstairs yes laura
the the nice young lady waving her hand
has a vial of heavy water from norse
kidro which you can look at
nearby is also a some some drinks and
refreshments uh which as far as i know
no do not contain heavy water but
for which we can thank the norwegian
embassy thank you very much uh so um i
hope you will join us at the reception
and let's uh please all
and and the book signing thank you you
can get your book signed down there you
can have a drink you can uh chat with
neil chat with our friends from the
norwegian embassy thank you for coming
and have a have a great evening thank
you everyone
okay
[Music]
[Music]
book tv is on instagram follow us for
publishing news